>>ASD, THA MUCH.NTIONED SSTODAYN
TO T
THE WEST TO DROPCTNSIPPLING RUSY
, LIFE O IDESPITR, LACK OF F
OUTAGESINNSBEAN
CITY WHERE RESIDENTS BARELY E S
RNUKRAINE. ARRIVEDAV PN IN THE
TH HBAKERIES DORSO THE 10,000,
TRKEVE
DAY.
HAS COMEH HER O
GRANDCHILDREN AND SAYS SHE TTO S
PLAYING WITH TSAYS.
U SHOULDT 'SATG .
TEOL HELPING
TO HAND OUT THE  LVI OU QUEST
EVERYTHING W FINE, GOD RE.UR
PAVLO'S JOB IS TO INVESTIGATE D
>>IKE YTE.IS THE.
WE DON'T KNO IT'G.>> HE TAKES U
RUSSIAWA PASSERIN T BEEND FOR
, LEX OF
AGRICULTURAL WOUSES HAS BEENWHCA
PN TF OF WARENTAINING
PRECIOUS RESOURCE. THE MOTIV
THE RUSSIAOR HITTING THIS
FACILITYN STRUSD
MOBUT ONE NNON ALL
TWOG AT THIS
CITY-RUN DRY SCHD THE LINGR
NEARBY TOW A
SAFER PART OF E COUNTRY BUNOUGHN
THE END ASKS, WHAT'S POINT?NS AE
IT'S THE SAM
SIANS, SHE MES,Y'R. AREN'T SOIS,
RE WAIT R TH
BUS OUT OF THE CWHY THEY
IGOR, A BEEKEEPEIN PVING WITH H.
MYLEFT EVERYTHINRE, HE SAYS, BE
THEY LOAD THEIR BAGS ON THE ANDL
WE SAW AMONGKRR
THEY WERE ABLE TSH
RUSSIAAC TIT